the protesters have feared the security
services storming their camp for weeks
and it started in the early morning unit
of the notoriously brutal rapid support
forces the RSF began clearing part of
the protest square but it rapidly
escalated into a full-on assault the
protesters scattered through the streets
of Khartoum with live rounds whistling
around them dozens have been killed or
injured in the clearance operation it's
unclear why it started but it's brought
chaos to the capital once again the
anti-government demonstrators set fires
and blocked roads and a bridge across
the Nile
they're promising to rise up against the
military and to attempt to take back
control hundreds of thousands have been
camped outside Sudan's military
headquarters for weeks
they force the removal of dictator Omar
al-bashir but talks on a transfer of
power from the military have stalled a
clear-out operation was always a
possibility although only weeks ago the
head of the military told me the
protesters would be safe sorrowful oh
man he my heart my god don't don't don't
yeah the RSF are now deployed across
Khartoum cars are being randomly stopped
drivers and passengers beaten it's
feared this is the start of a permanent
crackdown by at least part of the
security forces the leaders of the
protest movement are calling on people
to take to the streets across the
country and again in huge numbers the
military have said it still wants to
continue talks or whatever trust there
was between the two sides
we'll have all but disappeared now mr.
Ramsay Sky News